you know a general Robert Keller went on
to say conflicting signals can result in
loss of confidence confusion and
paralysis and the operating forces at a
critical moment so you don't want to
take her too much with the power of the
president this is absurd I mean it's it
actually and I think unconstitutional
for them to try and take the power away
from the president to order an immediate
strike if exigent circumstances require
it the commander-in-chief of the Armed
Forces why do you think worker and
others are saying this I'm in Corker
Heights trouble I mean I think it's
pretty clear that corker corker and
Trump don't get along anymore after a
corker did not become Secretary of State
now croaker is making a solid living I
think afterward
going around calling president from
crazy when who's willing to be a
Secretary of State for a few minutes
there but yeah this is this this sort of
talk that the Trump is going to randomly
launch nuclear weapons what I'm
wondering is yes Trump says ridiculous
things on Twitter sometimes I make fun
of him for the things he says on Twitter
sometimes has his activity as commander
in chief been this volatile that
everyone is seriously worried that he's
just going to randomly launch a nuke at
conjunct this plate right into his
strategy though yeah I mean I think it
does I think that every time Democrats
overreach I think every day or corker
anybody who opposes him over reaches by
suggesting that he is completely insane
and willing to launch nuclear weapons
because kim jongwan called him older say
he want kim jong-un to think that about
him and his strategy as well I mean I'm
not sure what no I'll be frank I don't I
don't know what he wants came gentleman
to think I mean I he tweets that kim
jong hoon is is fat and short so i'm not
sure what he wants I'm trying to think
and I think he would say the same thing
about me if you're watching the segment
but but that doesn't that betrays any
strategy on his part but beyond that I
don't think that if you look at how he
has conducted foreign policy there's
actually not much there to suggest that
he is doing it on a whim there's not
much there to suggest that he is doing
it just randomly that the most the the
most kind of knee-jerk thing that he did
was the missile strike in Syria which
was followed up by very little concerted
action in Syria and was widely praised
by both sides of the aisle actually
because he went after the use of
chemical weapons in a way that the
previous president was moving the line
so much that I got erased out of the
sand